[Müzik]
Kafalar dolu mu
Ses gelmiyor peki
yapalım gitsin Arkadaşlar niye
yapmıyoruz ki zaten Yani neden
yapmıyoruz Ben yaptığım için burada
olduğumu düşünmeyin
düşündüğüm için başta buradayım Burası
çok kıymetli bir yer sizin Bulunduğunuz
noktadan bakınca havalı duruyor ama bazı
şeyler havalı olduğu kadar da berbattır
Hatırlatırım ve bütün hikaye şimdi ona
da öyle kurgulayacağım filmin sonunu
başında söylüyorum yapalım gitsin
aklınıza bir sürü şey gelebilir bununla
alakalı
ben nasıl yaptım başardım mı kendimce
Evet bazen Ama benim böyle çok ilginç
tanımlarım var Ben Yasemin Şefik
anlatıcı
yazar
komikçi skeççi Yelkenci falanca falanca
böyle gidiyor bir sürü bir sürü bir sürü
tanım Bunların hepsi Beni anlatan şeyler
mi bilmiyorum yani yaptığımız her şey
bizi anlatıyor mu sizce bunu bu
kafanızda bir yerde şöyle bir tutun
Çünkü bazen öyle olmuyor işler Ben ilk
başta bundan 25 yıl önce 12
yaşlarındayken
televizyonda o zamanlar Körfez Savaşını
akşam yemeklerinde Canlı yayınlarda
izlerdik biz yemek yerdik o sırada ve
orada ilk gördüğüm şey şuydu Ben Savaş
Muhabir olmak istiyorum ilk gördüğüm şey
bu ilk gördüğüm şey bir Çarkıfelek kızı
ya da bir popçu da olabilirdi bu arada
Bunlar da gayet normal ama ben anlatmak
istiyordum Ben de anlatacağım orada bir
konu var ve ben de aktarmak istiyorum
Ama gel gör ki hayat Beni hiç o
düşündüğüm sistemin içinde dahil etmedi
Hani bazı insanlar için şey denir ya çok
şanslı Aslında şans
Tamamen açık olmakla alakalı birinin
gelip size bunu yapar mısın bunun içine
dahil olur musun dediği an itibariyle
Sen Evet ya dediğin an itibariyle şansı
açıyorsun deniyorsun denemek çok şanslı
bir kelime ama hayat bir deneyim bari
bir deneyim kısmında kötü bir Türkçe
Bir şekilde
kendine doğru noktada bulamayabilirsin
benim bütün kariyer hikayemde öğrendiğim
şey şu; istediğim hiçbir şey istediğim
anda olmadı Ve ben hep istediğim
hikayelerin dışında kaldım yani şöyle
düşünelim
kafamda bir plan var plan böyle bir
zincir olsun ilk halkası Bu ikincisi bu
Sonra bir baktım hayatıma
hiçbir birbirine benzemiyor Yani ben çok
o kadar çok sürüklenmişim ki oradan
oraya Oradan oraya Radyocu oldum ben
Diyeceksin ki Ne alaka Savaş muhabiri o
bir dergide staj yapıyorum o Junior
zamanlarım ve Yayın Yönetmeni dedi ki
aşağıda radyo var Sen çok güzel
anlatırsın gülersin eğlenirsin Çünkü bir
taraftan da o şey hali var ya hani her
şeye gülebiliyor ya da güldürebiliyor
odasını bilmiyoruz
çok bozulmuştum o sırada Çünkü benim
hayalim dergiden gazeteye gazeteden
Savaş muhabirlerine sahalara girmekti
ama ben bayağı bildiğiniz Çok eğlenceli
bir hikayenin içine dahil oldum ve
anlatıcılığımı oraya
evrildim tüm bunlar olurken basitmiş
gibi anlatıyorum ama İnanın bana basit
değildi çünkü hayatınızda ne yapmak
isterseniz isteyin Hep birileri kendince
yorumlayacak benim o zamanki mentorların
danışmanlarım Yani aklınıza ne gelirse
yöneticiler müdürler yayın yönetmenleri
Yani bütün o silsilenin İçinde gidip
geldiğim bütün fikirlerin içinde benim
dışımdaki bütün her şeyi dinleyip Buna
göre kendimi şekillendirmem gerekiyordu
bana kimin öğretisi çok minnettarım ama
ben en çok şunu yaptım bunu bilerek
yapmamışım Bu arada sonradan algılıyorum
bana bir bir şey öğretmeye başladığında
onun gibi yapmamayı tercih ettim ben
onun gibi olmayacağım dedim bu karakter
ya da işi yapma tekniği ile de alakalı
olabilir o yüzden teknikler çok önemli
ama tarzlar çok kıymetli çok iyi bir
tiyatro
hocasından aldığınız ders ya da o anki o
antrenman onun gibi yapmak zorunda
değilsiniz Ama ondan o tekniği almanız
gerekiyor sonra kendi tarzınızı
oluşturacaksınız tarz dediğim şey sadece
dış görünüşünüzden bahsetmiyorum sizin
kendi benliğinizle oluşturduğunuz bir
şey olacak bu bana kendi bütün hikayemin
içinde özellikle birçok meslekte şu
vardır cinsiyet etiketleştirme Yani bir
etiket var Ben bir kadın Radyo
programcısıyım bana hep şu söylendi
magazinsel şeyler anlat Neden ben kadın
olduğum için sabah kuşağı magazin
programı gibi program yapmak zorunda
mıyım o onun hakkında Bunun hakkında
diye konuşmalı mıyım Hayır ben her şeyi
anlatmak istiyorum bugün sokakta
yürürken başıma gelen bir şeyi hepimizin
Toplumsal olarak böyle
gelen bir konu üzerine herhangi bir
şakayı ya da çok ciddi bir algıyı
aktarmak istiyorum ve bunu İnanın bana
kendimce yapmaya başladım bundan keselim
22 yıl öncesine doğru gidelim 2000'li
yılların başında özel radyolarda İntro
denilen bir bölüm vardı dediler ki bize
o zaman fonların üzerine konuşuluyor
hani böyle
30 saniyem var İntro nedir şarkının
başladığı ve sözün geldiği yere kadar
giden kısım yani O baştaki müzik
30 saniyeniz var şu an şarkıların
introları yok farkındasınız
yani şu anki radyacılık sisteminde
biraz zarfında bana magazin anlat Her
şeyi anlatma diyen bir güruhun içindeyim
ve oradan Kendime şunu çıkardım Çok
basit bir teknik bildiğimiz edebiyat
derslerinde öğrendiğimiz giriş gelişme
sonuç bunu aldım 30 saniyenin içine
yaydım Süper bir şey yapmışım gibi
görünüyor ama çok basit bir şey herkesin
yapabileceği bir şey içine şaka koydum
çatışma koydum Bunu normal bir
arkadaşımıza kendimizle ilgili sıkıntıyı
anlatırken de öyle anlatırız ya ne
olduğunu anlatırız ne hissettiğimiz
nereye vardığını beraberde ne yapmamız
gerektiğini bütün hikayeyi buna
kurguladım ve Bu benim kendi tarzımı
oluşturan bir yapı olmaya başladı Benim
anlatma şeklim daha sarkastik daha
hicilliydi Kimisi için bu çok zor Kimisi
için çok kolay bu konu değil Hepimizin
bir alıcısı var Aşkta bile öyle yani bu
yanına birini buluyorsa İnanın bana onu
da alıcısı var
ama alıcı Olmak ya da hikayenin içinde
verici olmak tutkuyla bağlantılı yani
hayaliniz varsa onu Tutku evresine
geçirmeniz gerekiyor Tutku
ilhamla da çok böyle büyük aşk yaşayan
bir tanım tutmak Hayal ediyorsunuz
tutkunuz var ilham gelsin ilham gelir
ama ilham böyle çok
dönüşümlü bir sistem onu kullanmazsanız
bir hizmete bir harekete yarar açmaz
yani yapalım gitsin de hikaye şu denemek
zorundasın
mimar mısın yapacaksın o işi Çizeceksin
ve teslim edeceksin daha henüz değilim
diyorsun çizmeye devam edeceksin kitap
mı yazmak istiyorsun yaz İlla bir
yayınevinden çıkmak zorunda değil yaz o
hikayeden bir kurtul onu bir ayır ki
yenisi gelebilsin
sevgilileriniz için bunu yapmayın
O öyle bir sistemdi Ama aşk ilişkiler de
öyledir içindeki Tutku bakın ilk başta
şöyle başlar iki kişi
mükemmel bir başlangıç herkes en havalı
olduğu halini gösterir
ama çok başbaşasınızdır o dönemler sonra
iş sosyalleşmeye başlar aile arkadaşlar
kıskançlıklar tartışmalar bir sürü
şeyler çıkmaya başlar işte de böyledir
yani kariyer planınızda da böyledir
sosyalleşince işin içinde daha çok insan
dahil olunca birebir kalamazsın onunla
ve dış etken dediğimiz şey bizi yelkende
de çıkarız sabah Rüzgar gelir Çat diye
başka bir yerde Eser çıktığında kalırsın
hayatta öyle ilişkiler de öyle bazen çok
rutine oturur her şey rutini oturduğu
zaman da hep şey olur ilişkinizi düşünün
hayatınızın aşkını tutkusunu düşünün
rutin insanı yer bitirir ve hep biri
daha önce vazgeçer Vazgeçmek çok
önemlidir tutkunuzdan da
vazgeçebilmelisiniz biz birey olarak
değişebiliyorsak fikrimiz de değişebilir
mesela çok uçuk gelecek şu anda Çünkü
bazı şeyleri böyle çok saplantılı
şekilde tutkuluyuz ya futbol takımımızı
tuttuğunuz futbol takımı basketbol
takımı değiştirir misiniz Bence
değiştirebilirsiniz bu sene bu sezon
bunu tutuyorum arkadaş diyebilirsiniz
bütün çevreni size amiyanet abi ile
dönek olarak tabir eder ama bence
fikriniz değişebilir zor geliyor ama
değiştirebilirsiniz çünkü Bazen
vazgeçmek lazım Ben mesela radyo
programı geçen sezon
bir durdurdum bıraktım Yani Bıraktım
derken bir dursun dedim ne oluyor çünkü
hayat dijitalleşince Ben Radyo ile
ilgili kısmı sosyal medya ve Dijital
platformlara taşıyınca radyo dinleyicisi
dışında insanların da benimle ilgili
konuştukları paylaştığımız ya da
birbirimizi sevmediğimiz konuları ortaya
attığımız anlar oldu ve bu onu bir
şekilde başka bir yere taşımaya başladı
O yüzden vazgeçebilirsiniz şu anki
tutkunuzu hayaliniz inanın bilmiyorum
Onunla ilgili hiçbir şey yapmıyorsanız
hiçbir yere varmayacak şunu düşünün
Cihangir'de bir kafedesiniz kahvenizi
söylemişsiniz
karşınızda hep farklı insanlar geliyor
ve Siz hep aynı filmi anlatıyorsunuz
diyorsunuz ki ben bunu yazacağım bunu
çizeceğim ve bunu yapacağım yıllar
geçiyor böyle yıllar ve hiçbir şey
yapmıyorsunuz
dışarıdakilerine söylüyor önemli değil
Siz kendinize ne söylüyorsunuz böyle bir
mi olmak istersiniz yoksa
yaptım oldu ya da olmadığımı bütün
hikaye Orada başlıyor yapalım gitsin ki
o tutkuyla ilişkimiz başka bir tutkuya
dönüşsün tutku çok kolay bir kelime
söylemesi çok basit aşk gibi aşk her
yerde var ama çok kişiye özel bir mevzu
ya
işiniz de öyle işinizden
vazgeçebilirsiniz Ben mesela çok meslek
Ya kariyer hayatında çok farklı meslek
gruplarında aynı kategoride Duran
Yayıncılık ile ilgili ama çok farklı
meslek gruplarında yer aldım Yeri geldi
reklam metinini yazmaya başladım stand
up gösterilerine çıktım ki bugün hiç
komik değilim
Bazen hiç komik olmamamız Gerekiyor
bazen çok ciddi olabilirim bütün hepsini
denedim hayatımda
hayatınız kariyer planınız nasıl
başlarsa öyle gider diye bir şey yok Ben
de çok gençtim ve Bundan yıllar yıllar
evvelki halimle şu anki halim çok farklı
bir boyutta yani Seninki de değişecek
hemen küsme Çünkü yapmazsan küsersin
yapmadığınız zaman birinin o sözü
söylemediğiniz zaman o işle ilgili
planınızı aktarmadığınız zaman bir
ilişkide o anda net olmadığınız zaman o
fikirle sürekli kavga edersiniz ve o
konuya küsmeye başlarsınız
Her aşk hikayesinden sonra aşk acısı
çeken kişi ne yapar biliyor musunuz Ben
artık aşk istemiyorum ilişki bıktım
artık bitirdim der aradan biraz zaman
geçer deliler gibi aşık olur İşte böyle
bir şeydir kimi zaman küseceksiniz o bir
organizma kariyer planınız her şey
değişebilir şu anda çok bireysel bir
dünyanın içindeymişiz gibi bir hayır
Cumhuriyeti var biliyor musunuz Hayır
her şeye hayır diyebiliriz hayatınızda
öyle anlar olacak ki o işi yaparken o
hayatı yaşarken sizin Hayır diyeceğiniz
çok acayip şeyler çıkacak karşınızda Vay
be diyeceksiniz kimi zaman hayır diye
biliyorum kimi zaman da
ben buna Niye evet dedin diyeceksiniz Ne
olur bir şey yapın kendiniz için
hayaliniz için Tutku öyle bir şey ve
tutkudan vazgeçin aralarda işinize
yarayacak bir şey Teşekkür ederim
hepinize
[Alkış]